review the lymphatic issues related to chemotherapy, I recently developed a swollen right ankle very
weird as I have never had swelling and now weigh less than 100 pounds. So if you have a swollen
right ankle, what's that cause from? Well, there's some there's some blockage
in, so it's only on my right side, right? So why? So there's some blockage in that the
lymph systems ability to remove that fluid. The truth is, you're producing fluid
extra cellularly, constantly. So every cell of your body is is metabolically active. Every cell
of your body is producing waste. That waste is extruded outside the cell membrane into what's
called the extracellular space. The extracellular space is just space between cells and then you have
open ended capillaries, kind of like storm sewers, that drain the extracellular space.
And those open ended capillaries are called lymph vessels. Now the lymph vessels then pick up that
waste that waste flows into there. Well, how? By action of the muscle by contraction of the
surrounding muscles. So the only way waste, whether it's waste toxic waste or whether it's waste
that's just from autophagy of cell death or cell breakdown or cell metabolic processes,
that waste goes into the extracellular space and then it has to flow into the lymph system
to get out of the body. That's the only way it gets out of the body. So it's got to flow into that
storm sewer and it does so by contraction of muscles. So motion is so important. So if you're not
contracting your muscles, even the simple is just moving your feet around, moving your toes. So that's
another thing. It's just writing the alphabet with your feet or with your toes with your ankles.
Getting it up and doing some leg raisers, action of muscle contraction moves it into the
glove into the lymph vessels and remember their lymph vessels. Every several centimeters there's a
valve, a one way valve. So it can only go one way but it can't go back and it just keeps pushing
it, it pushes it, it pushes it until it gets to a vessel, it gets to a vessel in your body that's
going to then that's part of the vascular system and that's the venous system. So it doesn't go back
into the artery, it goes back into the venous system, it's going to be carried then back to the liver
where it's going to be pulled out of the liver. So if you have blockage in that lymph pathway
that's what's going to give you that that swelling like that. Now if you had swelling on both
ankles, then you'd start thinking possibly issues with sodium, potassium balance, etc. There's some
other blood chemistry issues why maybe you're just the vessels are losing fluid. So you can get fluid
build up in the extremities because your vessels become more permeable because of imbalance in
blood electrolyte activity. But if it's on one side, it kind of rules that out. It's more so
a lymphatic issue. Now a person can't lymphatic issues that they never do about because of an old
injury to there. Let's say this is your right ankle, let's say you hurt your right knee when you're
at high school. Don't you remember it anymore, but you actually damaged the lymph vessel,
but you haven't never even noticed any swelling in your right ankle before because you didn't go
through chemo. So you think of stings like that. But also think of structural things and maybe how
you're sleeping, are you pinching the lymph vessels in your, in your thighs that you're not getting
flow backwards. There's a lot of different structural things that you could possibly be thinking of.
You should have a patient that would cross their legs at work all the time in a certain way. That
was why they were getting swelling in one side. So if you're just Google a picture of your
lymph system, you could kind of see how that flow goes and how it goes back to the
vascular system to get out of the body so you think of things like that and how it could be blocked.
I do have blog posts on lymph exercises, I think, too, that goes over it in more detail and things
that you can do. There are some nutrients that can help lymph flow too. Some hoiopathy that can
let help lymph flow. Professional formulas make some things for lymph flow too. Cell core, I think,
makes a product for lymph stem. How well those work? I've had a people really love them and then
some people say it really didn't help them. But if there is structural damage to a lymph vessel,
this is the big problem with the rest of the cancer patients go in and they have surgery and they
remove primary lymph nodes and take on a bunch of lymph vessels and now they have swelling in their arm
all the time. It's very frustrating but they don't get in their oncologist surgical mind. They're
thinking we just got to remove everything that there's going to be cancer whether they leave the
person disabled with for different things so it is kind of a problem. So I would think of those kind
of things. I don't think it's a block chemistry issue. It's on one side. It's more of a structural issue
but on one side.